Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you. I'm just checking
in on you. This isn't even a podcast.
This is just me poking my head into
your cubicle or your office door.
You're fucking cardboard box wherever
you live in, wherever you work,
whatever you're doing.
Are you making American great again?
We go make it great again.
Remember what it was great
bad's going to happen again.
Making America great again.
Um,
what's going on? How are you?
I'm in a good mood. My, my,
my lovely daughter is entered a
new phase of just nonstop crying.
Ed.
Um,
I think she's going to be a ric flair
fan because the only thing I could do to
get her to stop was,
you know those exercise balls that uh,
the ladies use them.
You know,
cause they're always trying to work their
glutes and their fucking thighs cause
that's where they put the weight on.
You know,
guys are always over there doing sit ups a
gate. Yeah. Yeah. Doing that shit. Right.
Do it shit from rocky hanging upside down.
Well maybe if I hang upside down
and fucking do a setup, you know,
that'll offset the fucking nine slices
of pizza I'm going to have tonight.
The pizza wins. Okay. You
don't need to hang upside down.
You don't even need to do fuck.
You don't really even need to do setups,
which you need to do is you need
to get some salads and you're like,
you got to start looking at bad food.
Like it's some fucking check that you
know is great in the rack. Right. But it,
she's just, you can't bring it home to
your parents. She's a fucking lunatic.
That's,
that's what bad food is.
And the food version of great in the rack
is salt, sugar high. That's all this,
right? Just send you shit through
the roof. You like, yeah. You know,
and you just keep grabbing one fucking
handful after another is something in the
back of your head in the Becky
head is just screaming. No.
Like when you're dating a psycho,
why am I going to go out to a farmer's
market with this fucking lunatic?
Why am I pretending that
there's a relationship here?
Do you have a bag of chicken?
She's got a window right behind her bed
and halfway through bang, or you like,
what am I just opened this
and we'll fucking crawl down?
Yeah, I'm sure women have thought
that. You know what I mean?
Blade on that backs getting fucking railed
by some sweaty fucking, I don't know,
Banker Assistant. And then
he's got a skylight. Go.
What if I was like Spiderman right now?
I could just some fucking webs.
It just go right up and out of here.
Leave them all confused.
Half excited on the bed. That's what they
need to have with the future. Everybody.
They're trying to have better cameras
on your cell. Phone's better recorders.
Fucking, I don't know. Something
else. Whatever the fuck are.
They always have to be three examples.
So you fill in your last one.
This podcast will be interactive.
What did they come up with?
Something that when you're with
somebody, right, you could just,
you just hit a fucking eject button.
Look,
every house has like a fucking,
like even if you're on the bottom floor
and you just got to stand in the right
place and you remember those
old school offices would,
they would like send messages around
through that little fucking vacuum thing.
You know, you put the thing
in the tube, just do it.
Just disappear and go into
somebody else's office.
Sort of the original fucking emails.
They should have that for people you know
and yeah.
I'm telling you,
I didn't like the way you talked to my
sister and just remember we have that
data satellite Saturday and
you just, yeah, you just
go over to the fucking
portal and you just gone, hi.
Hi honey. Stop it. You're scaring me.
Hello. You still there? She walks
over and need just fucking gone.
Then it'd be the new thing instead
of getting dumped. You got port hold.
What's wrong with Maggie Paul?
She got porn hold right in the middle.
I think she was nagging him. You
know how Maggie is? She's very,
very particular and she, she, I
know. I love her too. I love her too,
but she can be hot. She can
be. She's a lot. She, she is.
And then that's when the other
girlfriends go. She gets a lot.
She's definitely a lot,
you know,
and then they fucking clink their little
fucking glass at Rosie, whatever it is.
Women doing the afternoon, ladies,
what do you do in the afternoon?
What does that little wind break you take?
You know,
like you fucking Ernest Hemingway, you
know, that's what I want to say. Uh,
I got it. I'm going to say something like
that at that writer's thing on Sunday.
Just talking about how much I booze now,
because I fucking sit in a writer's room
anyway,
so going through that keeps my,
my daughter quiet during this
phase that she's going through,
which is fucking awesome.
Even though she's crying her
brains out now. She's like,
she's like looking at Shit, you know,
she's like taking it in and everything.
It's an amazing thing, right?
So we got this exercise ball.
The thing that the ladies have right now,
maybe someone like Bill Clinton who
puts on weight like a bitch, right? Um,
lemme just big milky
fucking thighs. The, uh,
is during his first semester,
whatever the fuck they call it is
first trimester of being president.
Remember that Shit when he'd go
jogging in those fucking short shorts,
um, all I do anyways, uh,
you sit on that exercise ball okay.
And you bounce up and down.
And the only thing that keeps it
quiet as if I just, if I don't want,
I'm bouncing up and down.
If I just keep going,
whoo,
whoo.
You know?
And as much as it was driving me nuts,
as much as I was feeling my old spine
compacting, every time we went down,
um,
I held out this,
this glimmer of hope that maybe she's
going to be Rick Flair Fan, ric flair fan.
It's not easy to say. So anyways,
um, how was your Thursday?
You're almost there to get,
they give you a paycheck yet that was
always the best. You get your paycheck,
then you go out for lunch. Right. Do,
do you want to get a beer? Which I want,
but just have one. We'll
just have one. You know,
that whole fucking thing. What the
fuck is it? You know what it is?
Is Quality of life I would say.
What is it about life that you just can't,
you can 90% of the time you're not
doing what you want to be doing.
You know?
If there was no, I guess if there was
no infrastructure or assist society,
man, we probably only
live for fucking 30 years,
but just imagine but 30 years you could
do whatever the fuck you want but then
no one would have done anything and no
one want to taking the time to make a
beer factory so then you wouldn't
have a bar and then what would you do?
You'd just be sitting around trying
not to get eaten by animals. All right,
so are,
there we go.
We just figured out why you have to go
to work every week but isn't Thursday
exciting? I think that's the
point I'm trying to make here.
Thursday's are exciting because they
give you that piece of paper with the
numbers on it and then you write your
name on the back of it and then you go
down to those fucking crooked banker cons.
You give them that piece of paper with
the numbers on it and then they give you
a piece of paper back that added
more numbers to the numbers that were
previously on that piece of paper.
And then you walk around buying shit.
Isn't that what you do?
Okay.
I have no fucking idea.
That was another thing I liked about that
old guy who smoked 12 cigars a day and
he lived east 109 he's still going like
one of the oldest World War II veterans
out there. Um, what I liked about
him was he paid cash for everything,
paid cash for everything,
you know, just completely,
you know,
I wonder if you just slip through the
cracks after awhile you came into this
world and you just paid
cash for everything and you
never went on the Internet.
You know,
somebody is still take a fucking selfie
with you. And then that would be it.
Everybody,
like,
who is this guy who is this mysterious
guy that's never been on the Internet and
pays cash for everything?
You know,
all the advertising world
would be all obsessed.
We don't know what kind of toothpaste
to use as we can't have that
start to fucking spying on him
was like a drone and shit. Um,
I don't know what's going on here.
I just had a bowl of cereal.
Maybe that's what it is.
I thought it was a healthy bowl.
Do you guys like the checks? Family of
cereals? I'm big on the checks families.
Speaking of which so many cereals
have just fucking disappeared.
When my wife was pregnant, when
she was pregnant. Oh my God.
Um, when she was pregnant, um,
she was requesting all these fucking
cereals, you know, from back in the day.
For some reason I'm thinking they'd be
the ending of Star Trek right now. Right.
Wow.
She wanted alphabets. They don't
fucking make those anymore. Some,
some how you can go to target,
you know, that involves,
that involves like, you know, going into
a mall. It's one of those anchor stores,
you know, which is the goal of
anybody with the small business.
Someday I'm going to be an
anchor store and a fucking mall,
then then I'll be happy.
Right.
And you got to fucking deal with the
parking garage and then you like following
somebody like a serial killer, is it
trying to get back to their fucking car?
And then they get in there and they start
checked in the text messages and the
person behind you starts beeping and
it just becomes like, you know what?
It just becomes one of those things where
you just had to be like, you know what?
Fuck this cereal. Fuck
alphabets. Fuck booberry count.
Chocula Frankenberry sugar corn smacks,
honeycomb. Fuck all of these cereals.
I don't know where they are anymore.
You know what they're like,
they're like old music acts that
play casinos. You know what I mean?
Like loverboy.
Yeah,
there's somewhere right now, this
weekend, and they're going to sing.
Everybody's working for the weekend right
there somewhere. Do, do, do, do, do,
do, do, do
you want a piece of my heart?
Tell me that lead singer didn't kind of
look like Dan Marino back in the day. Um,
anyways, that's why I like old cereal is
like, they're, they're on the casino tour.
Did Not grow up my grocery stores as
far as serial goes. Food in general.
When you're in all the grocery stores,
that's you're at the height of your
career, right? You're Bruno Mars,
you doing the fucking prince
thing at the grammys, right?
And then somewhere, you
know, but you're on the deer,
right at the fucking mid level
shelf to your headline, headlining,
maybe even the top shelf,
but right at fucking eyeball level,
whatever average hiatus,
you're right fucking there.
Sandwiched between the CEC cereals of uh,
check family of cereals. And then you've
got the corn flakes on the other side.
You're right there.
You're big stupid fucking face.
And whenever sugary Horse Shit,
you're selling to the public, right?
And then somewhere along the line he,
it just, you know, you run out of hits,
you collaborate with the wrong people,
people's palettes change and then
you get, you get, you get pushed out,
you know?
Yeah.
You start going to those places where,
you know,
you can only get them in certain cities.
You are only in target like Michelob.
MMM.
Michelob light,
Michelob light.
The only place I've been able to buy
that was in the city of New Orleans.
Once Michelob ultra came along, it just
completely fucked over Michelob light.
I don't know where it went.
So first beer I ever got drunk on.
I love that beer.
I love me some make a low black and um,
I dunno. I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about.
I was just asking the guys you'd
like to check cereals. You know,
I didn't want to do a whole eighties
fucking comedy routine on cereal. Did I?
You know, I'll fuck it. Let's keep going.
Then he got Wheaties is like the Frank
Sinatra, you know, like the rat pack.
Like they're never going away. They're
timeless. Fucking classics, you know,
fly me to the moon.
It is fucking shit.
That's really not good for you.
Fucking Bruce Jenner didn't eat this.
That's not why he won the gold medal.
In other words, he's a whore. Um, anyways,
he got Wheaties. What are the classics?
Grape nuts. They're hanging in there.
They're on the bottom shelf. Grape
nuts. His bottom shelf. You know,
they're still there. They're still
playing the fucking, you know,
the play in the big rooms,
but not the Abrams, you know,
was another one that's hung around for
a long fucking time. Brighten up flakes.
So the Billy Carter of the fucking
grape nut family. All right.
I'm done with this fucking
shit. Anyways, let's,
let's talk about what's really
important out there. Nick Depaulo,
one of the fucking greatest comics I've
ever seen is new special is on right now
on Seeso T. I actually at 8:00 PM tonight,
you got to fucking watch this thing.
You don't have to,
but I would really appreciate if you did,
it's called inflammatory.
It's debuting today,
February 16th at 8:00 PM on Seeso TV,
s e s o a TV to subscribe
to his pod podcast.
Just go to connect
pal.com/nick all lowercase connect pals,
c o n n e c t p a
l.com/nick. Um, that's what I'm
doing. I don't know what you're doing,
but that's what the fuck I'm doing.
Um,
oh Joey roses also has a
special on comedy central,
but comedy central is weird cause
they don't stream. They're not weird.
They're old school. You know
what I mean? You know what?
They're not streaming anymore.
So that channel there at target right now
and Netflix,
Netflix elbowed him out.
See sews elbow there that
they're the new, the new, uh,
though they like the millennials
of fucking TV networks
and they just cut in all
these cons out, you know, and these other
guy, right? A kid you had to buy cable,
Eh, yard to watch
commercials. Um, all right,
there's the elephant in the room and I
have to address and I know every fucking
French content from Montreal
with your silly socks. Oh,
you're clapping right now,
aren't ya? Huh. All right.
So as I, you know, not
everybody saw it coming.
You knew a Clo Julian was going to take
the fall for some of the moves that
we've made and uh, you know, it,
and I was saying the entire fucking time
that this guy wanted us our first cup
and 40 years, you know, um,
why are we blaming this fucking guy? Yada,
Yada, Yada. Please don't fucking fire.
And what do they do? They
fire him. So I tweeted out,
congratulations to any NHL team out there
that's looking for a great coach that
knows how to win a cup. All
right. Now having said that,
I had no fucking idea.
I ain't no fucking idea
that the Montreal Canadians,
we're going to fire
their coach was a Tarion.
They fired him all right.
And fucking picked him up.
And um, as much as I hate to say this
is a Bruins fan, we fucking deserve it.
You know, I dunno. You know what
happens is everybody does it. They,
they were doing well with Pat Burns at
Pat Burns. Got fucking sick of them.
I always thought pat one a copy then
86 and 93 with him. I guess he didn't,
he existed in the middle
like don Mattingly. Um,
yeah.
And um, I dunno, I have no idea, but
I think I'm going to say right now,
the Canadians are going to win a cup with
Cloe. Julian, if before you get excited,
you want for your fans.
If they will want a cup,
if they're dumb ass fans in the media,
don't run them out of town first.
God knows they love doing that.
Fucking dopes have you concept there.
You know what I mean?
Why don't you get out there and skate
around for the little fucking pocket
square fucking bitch
moaning and complaining.
The most arrogant fans on the
face of the fucking earth.
Without a fucking doubt.
Montreal Canadien fans.
New York fans are pretty bad, but there's
just something about him did dumb.
You just hear it.
They fucking breathe through their
mouths to eat big sandwiches.
They walk around in sweatpants that get,
you know,
a guy like Paul Versey you consider
considers dressing up, Eh, uh,
putting on a new pair of jeans and
some Air Jordans and a sweater.
I swear to God, if Paul put
that outfit on, he'd be like,
I'm ready to meet the president.
Okay, that's your average New Yorker.
But they've written so many songs blowing
that city that people think they're a
cut above just cause they, you know,
their parents had unprotected sex there.
You know all those songs.
Yeah. Phi can make it.
Dad Do, will you? Will
you make it anywhere?
Most New Yorkers can't even
live outside of New York.
They have a fucking panic attack. The
second they get out of the two, one, two,
seven, one eight fucking
area code, they're horrific.
They hold onto it like they move out
here to La and they keep wearing this
stupid fucking New York badge.
You know,
like some washed up athletes still
wearing his highschool fucking jacket.
They just keep, they come out to La and
all they do is shit all over. It's like,
go back. You're dumb cunt. You know,
you're going to go back. You're out here.
Why don't you enjoy it? The learn how
to surf. Go have a fucking Burrito.
Go on a hike. I'll write already
with the fucking New York Shit. Oh,
the Adh fucking plays where
you get the fucking linguine.
You're the fucking 78
can fucking if today. Um,
I don't know. Look, I'm fucking,
I'm not going to take responsibility for
anything that I say in this podcast. Um,
first of all because, uh, I'm not an
adult and second of all, because, uh,
the lack of sleep I've
had recently, um, yeah,
so the New York fence, this, there's still
an element of the, of just, you know,
they're morons. They're like
Boston fence, Philly fans.
We're all mouth breathing fucking
morons now. The Canadian fans, okay.
The Canadian fans, because they
don't live in the United States,
they live in Canada.
They actually have to take the time
to learn about other countries.
You know what I mean? Which makes
them appear to be more intelligent.
But I'll tell you,
there's some of the most racist
fucking people I ever met in my life.
They lose a playoff series. They burned
down their fucking city. They ran,
Patrick was out of town. Okay? The
fucking Hornets nest that closed.
Julian just stepped into,
if they can somehow keep those people
at bay and this stupid ass media,
the fucking media,
those Fed Fox,
like they're gonna go out there and start
skating if they don't run him out of
town.
I'm telling you right now,
if all of you fucking
Montreal counts can give,
just keep you fucking Yap shut.
Okay,
go buy yourself another pair of
loafers and some silly fucking socks.
If he can just shut your fucking
mouth and stop acting like,
you know how to run a team, this guy could
bring your cup. I'd say you got a 50,
50 chance cause they're not
gonna be able to, they, you know,
they can't sit on their hands.
They can't,
they speak French. You know, there's
something about speaking French.
All of a sudden you think you know stuff.
Unless you're in France,
I want to go to France. So those
people are cool. You got to Montreal.
I don't know what the deal is.
Um,
so much of that was just
absolute misinformation and
I really enjoyed all of it.
Um, you know what?
Congratulations to quote Julian.
I'm really happy we went to another
original 16. I hate the fucking Canadians,
but I'm adult enough to not,
uh, to not sit there. I mean,
I hope he wins another fucking cup.
I don't want the Canadians to do it,
but I liked him too much to,
to have to fucking root against them.
I will only root against him when it's
hard because he's with the Canadians.
But like, obviously if the
Bruins are playing, I'm going
to root against them. But,
uh, he's just a fucking
class act, you know,
he said he's going to
keep the rivalry going on,
but he said something nice
about the players and all
of that. And uh, we'll see.
We'll see. The only thing that
can screw this up is the moron,
Canadian fans and their media. You know,
if you can run Patrick out of town,
maybe this ends the curse, the curse of
Patrick Walk, who knows? We shall see.
But uh, I just became a,
when he went to Montreal,
I just became a huge penguins
and Washington capitol Fan.
I will be rooting hard, not against cloud.
I just don't want to see the fucking,
I love that they haven't won one in 20,
24 fucking years.
They're going on a quarter of a century
for any other franchise that's totally
acceptable,
but not for them.
They have to win a cup.
That's all they have.
This is what one thing have sympathy.
I will say actually I, you know,
I love the city Montreal. I'm fucking
around with you guys. Beautiful women.
And you guys got fucked in 1994 and that
would have been so for baseball if the
Montreal expos even made it to a
world series, forget about winning.
I'm winning the whole damn thing. And they
had a young Pedro Young Randy Johnson.
I mean they were fucking stacked.
And um,
I love nationally baseball.
My whole time growing up,
whenever I used to watch this week in
baseball, it was always a faster game.
It was hit and run.
They had all the astro turf,
which I thought was cool when I was a
kid. And uh, you know, I will, you know,
I watch the Red Sox,
we were all American league.
We QC just keep signing one fucking
home run, hit her after another,
another lefty. I'll tell you if
this guy please in Fenway park,
he's going to hit 80 home runs. And all
he did was just ground into double place.
Like the pitcher doesn't know
why he was brought to town.
They just fucking low and inside high
and inside those kinds always loved those
pitches. Low. The low
ball, they'd fucking,
whatever the fuck they would do at
sync around my a big baseball guy,
they'd always would ground out and then
they just work them right up the ladder
in that fucking high heat on the inside.
They could never lay off.
It's g three into the attic.
Red sox leaving another six rudders
stranded. It's not possible,
but that's what it felt like two runners.
Right. All right. All right. Whatever.
I was never good at math. All right, let's
read some advertising here, shall we?
All right. Frame Bridge.
Uh, okay. Frame Bridge.
Do you have a thousand photos living
in your phone and not a single one in a
frame? Give your personal
experience using frame bridge.com.
I've never used it. Why? Frame Bridge,
dude.
What am I going to do?
Frame a bunch of pictures of me taking
pictures of people who took their shoes
off on a plane. Um, I don't take pictures
like it, but if you do take pictures,
if you do this, this is for you
because you know what happens.
What ends up happening is you lose your
phone or your laptop craps out and if he
didn't put it on the cloud, then you
just going to lose these fucking photos.
I don't know how many photos I've
taken with my cell phone. I don't,
I don't have any of them. I
don't know where any of them
are. Um, it's easy to use.
Evidently.
Go to frame bridge.com choose your frame
or let their designers help you choose.
Upload your photo from your
computer or directly from Instagram.
Preview your photo online in the frame
you choose can upload your photo art.
No worries.
You can mail it in for free.
Instead of hunt the hundreds
you'd pay at a framing store,
their prices start at $39
in all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners get 15% off their
first order to frame bridge.com when they
use my code.
Burr B U R R go to frame
bridge.com and use Promo code bar.
You'll save an additional 15% off
your first order. Just go to frame
bridge.com/burr once again. Hey, that's
frame bridge.com/prime mister paragraph.
Evidently they have an expert team at
frame bridge that we'll custom frame your
item in days, not weeks
or month days. Okay?
That's way quicker than weeks or
months and delivery and deliver at your
finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang.
Frame Bridge offers a happiness guarantee.
That team gives each item personal
care and attention because meeting your
expectation is as important as meeting
their own. There you go. There.
An old school business,
they're going to treat you right.
Frame branch.com Promo Code
Bar. All right. Oh Jesus Christ.
Bateau Popo me on days beyond DDS.
Julian to the Habs Badu.
[inaudible] beyond these all the friends.
These are so glad.
[inaudible] they're running around like
a bunch of Douche is with the silly
socks and pocket squares, but they're
fucking balls are nice and soft.
Just like they're fucking morals.
They're always outside their
marriages. Um, alright me undies.
Elevate your underwear game to the
next level with me on these. Uh,
you've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've
been setting a settling for store bought
underwear,
five packs.
I have something that will change your
life for the better me undies one is me
undies out. Just seriously
soft. Feel good on these.
Delivered right to your fucking door.
We and these are designed in La and made
from sustainable source. Micro modal.
Oh now it's micro modal. A fabric
three times softer than cotton. Well,
how did it become micro?
And it's still just a soft,
there must've been a reason for it. Me
undies softer than soft, softer than soft.
Smattered in Smad,
luxury undies coming and ever
changing selection of classic colors,
bold shades and adventurous patterns so
you can tailor your undies to your own
personal style.
Guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
How much he is shitting yourself that you
need to get new underwear every month.
And if you're not ready for subscriptions,
that's okay.
You can still say this because me undies
is offering you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bird to get
20% off your first pair. Holy Shit.
So go ahead. Revamp your underwear
drawer. You deserve it. Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] [inaudible] dot com slash Barb
alright. Indochino Indochina, uh,
talk about how a man made to measure
suit fits compared to a generic off the
rack suit. Well, isn't that
self explanatory? You know,
unless you're a mannequin measurements,
right?
Which you're really weird now.
You know what I mean?
They got like the shredded ones.
They finally don't just
have all white mannequins.
They blood other races of people you know,
that aren't allowed,
that aren't alive to be allowed
to fucking model clothes. Um,
I don't need to talk about
what the, obviously, hey,
if he just grabbed a random fucking suit,
that sort of fits.
Is that not as good as having one?
That's fucking Taylormade. It don't,
shadow is one of the largest
made to measure men's wear.
Brands get high quality.
Get a high quality suit made to your
exact measurements for a perfect fit yet
then you've got to stop eating well,
not stop it.
And you've got to keep your calorie
intake the exact fucking same way you can
get a accustomed.
You can.
You also get to customize your
suit just the way you want it.
Here's how it works.
Visit a showroom or shop
online@indochino.com I n d
o [inaudible] c h I n o.com.
Uh,
pick from hundreds of fabrics.
Choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings and more.
What are pleats? I know what
lapels are, aren't pleats,
those fucking lines people used to
have in their pants in the 1980s. Uh,
submit your, and I'm not talking about
creases. I mean the ones up, N***a Dick,
or you're a VJ Jake,
as Oprah says, summit,
summit, submit your party measurements,
place your order and wait for it.
Why? What? It's going to arrive in
just four weeks with this this week,
my listeners can get any premium
Indochino suit for 389 bucks,
indochino.com uh,
at indochino.com when
entering burr at checkout,
this is perfect if you're just
entering the business world,
you want to look good with the fucking,
you know, cheap suit, you know,
not cheating a bad way, but you know, if
you don't have to spend a lot of money,
that's 50% off the regular price
for made to measure premium suit,
you can customize it so no one has the
same one as you. Plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code bar for
any premium suit for just 389 bucks and
free shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could. So there you
go. There affordable suits,
but they're actually fitted like your
hosting the tonight show or a late night
with Conan O'brien. Well, the
Jimmy Kimmel show and talk show.
All right, we're almost done here.
Oh, this is the last one. CSO,
which tonight we'll have nick
depalo new special at 8:00 PM. Uh,
ever hear the saying laugh at the world,
laugh in the world, laughs with you.
Uh, yeah, I've had that, but
I've never really thought
about it. Laugh in the world.
Let's, yeah, stepping on a bus
and do that. See what happens.
So we laughing at you. Laugh in
the world lasts with you or at you.
Depending on the situation, I think is
the way it should be. All right. Anyways,
well I hate to tell you,
but the world has left you in the dust
because they've already signed up for CSO.
You know, I just blew their whole
joke. Let me, let me start over again.
Ever hear the saying laugh in the world.
Laughs with you. Well, I hate to tell you,
but the world is left in the dust because
they've already signed up for CSO.
In other words, they're already
laughing over there without you.
The ad free companies streaming service
with a huge library of standup TB and
original content. The world will be
laughing whether you join in or not.
So you might as well get on board with
CSO. You get unlimited access to CSOS.
Original series is next day, late
night, hilarious. Standup specials,
binge worthy classics including
42 seasons of Saturday night live,
the entire money python catalog,
the it crowd and more with
Cso Jesus, the guy with the leaf
blower. Can you get that with CSO,
you get binge worthy classics,
British called comedy, uh,
original series like Carmen quests
and bajillion dollar prize property.
What? But Jillian. Oh, bajillion dollar
properties. That's how you spell.
But Jillian,
I didn't think that was a word.
Not to mention the entire
SNL library library,
including new episodes the day after the
air plus CSO brings stand up right to
your living room with exclusive
content from today's best comedians,
including nick depalo tonight at
eight on demand and commercial free.
Signup now to catch brand new standup
specials from Brian posts saying Nick
Depalo and
Joey go Diaz ready brother will live.
And like doctors,
um Oh watch your favorite sets
from comedians like Louis Ck,
Amy Schumer and Hannibal Buress access
CSO content from anywhere at any time
using Ios, android, Roku,
apple TV, Amazon fire TV,
windows or Xbox one. Ready for the
punchline. CSO is just three 99 per month.
Jesus Christ, I gotta to sign
up for this shit. No joke.
Three 99 per month for all the comedy
you want. Anytime, anywhere ad free.
I might do that just to
watch fucking all 42 seasons.
Just go to seeso.com s e s o.com right
now and sign up for one month for free
with Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
This is the best offers CSO has right now.
One month for free of laughing your ass
off comedy at Cso just by using Promo
Code Burr.
That's seeso.com Jesus Christ
spelled s e s o.com Promo Code Bar.
They got a red and again, seeso.com
promo code bar. Fuck. All right,
it's over. Hey, speaking as much as
our clothed Julian has has left, uh,
what's his face? Uh, Bruce Cassidy is
undefeated and we beat the Canadians.
Shut those fuckers out.
Four to, nothing for to zip.
I didn't realize Tuukka Rask. It was
like, oh nine in three at the TD bank.
North Garden lifetime against
the Canadians. I had no idea.
He had never won at home.
That's fucking weird to me.
My baby was the other guy. Can't
remember his name was that goaltender.
We won the fucking cop.
The guy would go to the White House and
then took a year off to go find himself.
And then I never heard from him again.
I think you went to the panthers.
Anyways, let's fucking plow ahead
here. Shall We? Um, oh Billy,
no booze.
No cigars is still fucking cruising along.
I took my life insurance test
and a fucking guy took blood.
Jesus Creek, he was, I
couldn't find the vein.
He fucking hacked up my arm big time.
That's going to bruise a little bit.
And you know what he was
right. But anyways, I kind
of liken not smoking cigars.
I haven't smoked since last
year. I like saying that. So, um,
I think I'm gonna go on, go on a little
run, you know, no booze, no cigar.
I'll tell you a kid.
We'll keep your fucking sober,
you know,
instead of looking fondly for that
fucking glass of Scotch at night.
Now are you thinking about is oh my God,
when this kid goes to sleep,
when this go kid goes to sleep,
I'm going to sleep and I am going to
have to log on to treat all fucking not
away.
That's all I,
that's all I care about right now is just
getting a little bit of sleep. But uh,
but it's been fucking awesome man.
I'm already watched and change in
watching now. When she looks at stuff,
she could really like kind of take it in.
And I was still waiting for
the first smile. I still
think it's, she just has gas.
If she's going to the bathroom.
Um,
he started smiling and he think
they're smiling at you and you're like,
oh my God, you smelling
me? And then you know,
you kind of drift out of their line of
vision to see if they're still looking at
you and then they just continue looking
where your head was. It's just like, oh,
all right, I guess you're
not. Um, so anyways,
so if I'd done my contractually obligation
obligated 33 minutes, 30 minutes,
whatever the fuck I'm supposed to do on
this. Um, by the way, still loving my car.
I'm loving it more than ever. I
had to put my truck in storage. Uh,
so what I do is on the weekends I
just drive my car over to the storage.
I switched them out and um,
eventually, eventually my next, uh,
my next house,
cause the layout of my house.
I don't know if this is going to work
with one kid or if we decide to have
another one. I don't know if it's
gonna work out because it's either,
we're upstairs in the kids downstairs,
we're downstairs and the kids upstairs
and it just doesn't fucking work out.
So I don't know. Maybe I'll have to move.
I have no idea. But I will tell you this,
the next fucking place that I move,
I don't give a fuck about a view I'll,
I give a shit about is a fucking driveway
that you know is act that isn't built
for a model t fucking fort that
is built from modern day cars.
I would love to have the
fucking circle driveway.
You know those people like on Dallas
[inaudible] mandate a big fucking ranch,
you know,
they have their own fucking street just
driving all the way down there and I'm
just have anything, a little carport
someplace in my truck that, that is,
that's all I don't give. I mean,
when I pictured my dream house,
I don't even think about the house.
All I think about is to driveway,
the garage,
the garage.
I got a gym and I got a
fucking a little drum room,
you know,
and I got a place in my truck and my
car and when I come out I don't have to
move like 20 fucking cars
to get my fucking car on.
I don't have to move 20 guys have
to move my car, my wife's car.
But I feel like a valet, you know,
that's all I give a shit about.
I don't give a,
I don't give a fuck about the rest of
the house that the rest of the house is
for your wife. They liked
that shit. This social. Okay.
Men need to get away from shit. If I can
have in this fucking garage. All right.
If I can just have a little place where
I can work out and I got a place where I
can play drums and I got my old
truck and I got my car. I mean,
what the fuck else do I need?
You know, right there. I'm good.
Like I actually think my dream house
is just a garage with a room above it,
you know? And the garage has
enough room for two cars.
A modern in a classic. The back
is the gym and then the drum room.
And then upstairs is a little fucking
kitchen. Flatscreen TV, right.
Little fucking humidor and whatever the
fuck else you need do. Maybe that's,
you know, something. All this
whole downsizing in life.
That's a fucking great idea.
Oh Shit.
That fucking divorce guy's house.
That's all it is. And you just
make an entire fucking street,
you know, so they can still
make the child support payments.
They can still pay their
alimony and all they,
all these fucking women out there
whining about how they know, hey,
I don't make as much money. Yeah, you
do. You get your check and his check.
So many of you do and you're still going
to those fucking rallies standing out
in the rain, listening
to Alicia keys. Yeah.
The fuck out of here. Um, what Nia,
everything that I've said,
you're going to stare at me for that.
They need to listen to this
idea. Come here. Come here.
Yeah.
Oh, come on. Don't be like that.
Can we? I have a great idea.
She goes, don't be like what
an asshole like you. Ooh,
what are we at the bus stop?
Come here.
I'm saying that that insult was on the
level of somebody standing at a bus stop.
I'll look at the blue QT cakes. What
do you say to I love on softer feeding.
Huh? You have a daughter now. So what
does that mean? You know what that means?
Yeah, it means I have to be extra funny
cause now I got two of you ladies.
I'm paying for her. You funny is
this, is this what you consider funny?
Move out of the way. I want
to put it down. Don't kiss
me and try to make it cute.
Oh, shut up. Listen to me and sit down.
I get an idea to force
the divorce guys house.
Okay.
All right.
So all it is is it's a two car garage
in the back there's a little gym.
If you play drums like me,
there's a little drum room
and above it is just this,
just like almost like a loft and that's
your kitchen, your flat screen TV,
your bed.
Just the only thing that you need.
Because when I think of our dream house,
I don't even think of the house. That's,
that's all I want.
Is that,
do you think that would work if I had
a whole street of fucking divorce,
divorce guys, they're all paying
alimony. All play child support.
All you strong women go into court. You
go to a woman, I can't afford to do,
what am I going to do in the real world
and they have to give no idea when
anybody goes through and divorce and
having to get alimony or any of that kind
of stuff. So yes I do. Cause I've
divorced, man. I've talked to divorcement.
You talked,
have you talked to any divorce women
about it or are you just on one side? Yes,
I did. Oh, I talked to a
lot of them on Rodeo drive,
man. The money, the money,
I get my check and I get his fucking
check to town. Curse in front of the baby.
Okay. A man, the money, I'm in the money,
I get my check and I get his
freaking too. That's better. Huh?
You like that? That was take two. You guys
just got the extra the outtake. Alright.
Um, oh, look it up. Look up
cute cheese. All right. Um,
I gotta I gotta close this up here.
Um, thank you guys for, for listening.
I can't say this word for my daughter.
You know what I say?
You so and so's have a great weekend.
I'll talk to you guys.
Go F yourself. Go F yourself.
Don't take any s from anybody. Um,
I'll talk to you guys on Monday and,
uh, congratulations to Clode. Julian,
forgetting the respect you deserved.
You were unemployed for what?
Two or three days? Uh, best of luck to
you even though you with the Canadians,
unless you play in my thoughts.
All right, I'll see you
foil the Chet cats
walking
it.
Don't vote a drip. The Suva, Chris,
we'll start out through the
[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on? It is
edit is the Monday morning
podcast for Monday,
February 16th,
2009 in the year of the fucking,
what is it?
What is it the year of
in China?
What animal is it?
Do you ever,
that's one of those dumb conversations
you have in a bar when they'll have like
a poster of land on the wall.
Like what year were you born in?
You were born the year of the monkey.
I can see that. I can see that.
No, totally. I can see that.
Shut up. You're dumb cunt.
Okay. You don't have anything to say.
It's okay to just not say anything.
You don't have to just start looking at
shit on the walls and trying to force a
conversation.
Why don't you just stare straight ahead
and think about how you ended up here.
You know how you can change things
in the future so you won't have this
screaming sound of fucking regret in
your head all the time to the point that
you're going to need to try to drown it
out with some stupid fucking shit about
a poster on the wall in this shithole bar.
Oh God.
That felt good. Um, it's raining
out here right now in California.
Rainy days and Mondays always get me out.
I fucking hated that song. Who Sang
that song? That was the carpenters.
You know there's a woman to let shit
get to her, Huh? Oh, it's raining out.
I think I'll go throw up my breakfast.
That's your fucking, that was,
that was really, really fucking
mean. That was really mean.
I apologize to the Karen
carpenters state for that one.
I'm gonna make a donation to a,
the bulemia fund. You know what?
Someone's going to take that joke really
seriously and I'm going to get some
more fucking hate mail,
which I get on these things quite a bit,
sometimes quite a bit.
Sometimes you like that I say quite a
bit and I'm thinking in my head, no,
I really don't quite a bit. It's actually
sometimes, so I try to fix the lie,
but anyway, someone's going to fucking,
uh, not even a lie. It was just like,
I was just exaggerating cause you know,
it's just what you do.
You know what I mean?
Like he just exaggerate.
You just get used to exaggerating
whatever the fuck it is you do.
You know what I'm doing right
now and doing the exact thing.
I just was given that hypothetical woman
who was talking about the poster in the
bar. I was giving her shit about doing
it and then I turned around and I did it,
you know,
so now someone else has to have a podcast,
trash and me and that's how it starts.
Did that make sense? I didn't think so.
Um, yeah. So if you guys, if you've
never been out here to California,
at least the southern part of
it, uh, people always, you know,
they talk about the weather out here, how
it's like groundhog day, how you know,
every day is the exact same. Only
good if he did 70 and beautiful loads,
you get sick of it.
And I used to be that person,
but I kind of am starting to understand
the weather out here and it's pretty
fucking fascinating.
Basically what happens is at
the beginning of the year,
usually I guess this time of
year, around January, February,
it rains almost every day for a month.
Almost every fucking day it rains.
And what it does is obviously
it builds up. Oh Jesus.
I've really talked myself
into a corner here.
I really don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about,
but it's not going to stop me from
plowing through this. I was like,
it builds up the shrubs and green things.
Like I didn't even know what
fucking word to use there.
Just basically a Hollywood hills, you
know, they usually like, you know,
Brown and that type of shit because
we live in a desert. But, uh,
after a month of this stuff,
everything becomes really green
and really beautiful and uh,
you know,
then it stops raining and then it's 70
degrees out and everything's green and
it's fucking gorgeous out here.
But what happens is over the,
over the course of the year,
because we live in a desert, uh,
all that Green Shit starts to turn
Brown and it starts drying out.
And then when the Santa
Ana winds come across,
it drives the shit out of it.
And then that's around fall.
And that's when we have fires out here.
And the funny thing is,
is the fires are completely natural.
People out of here for some reason,
they act like they're fucked
up. Like, oh my God, the fire.
I just jumped over the flow of Holy Shit,
let's get to have,
and we sit there and we try to put the
fire out, which we shouldn't be doing.
Nature is taken it's fucking course.
It's burning out all that green shit.
And what the firemen dude is,
they put the fucking fires out and
they leave a bunch of brown shit.
You know,
that should have burned up but now isn't.
And then next year the fire's
going to be even worse than,
it's just the typical shit.
Like we think it's a tragedy because
nature is doing what it naturally does.
And it's not nature's fault.
Some fucking idiot built a house in the
middle of Shit that turns brown every
year and catches on fire. You
know what I mean? Would you know,
would you sit in a fireplace? Would
you build a house in a giant fireplace?
I wouldn't do that.
So what I'm trying to say is the fucking
living in the hills is overrated.
Do you want to live down here in the
flat lands while the apartment buildings
and well,
one palm tree catches on fire.
I mean the amount of people jogging by
with water bottles can put that shit up
with those fucking people who
live up in the hills. The crazy,
not to mention all the fucking desal
dries out because there's so little water,
right?
Because we live in a desert,
the soil dries out to like literally
like the top six inches is like fucking
bone dry.
So then when it rains like this,
that's what causes your mud slide
because evidently it can't absorb it.
It's like Dandruff and it just washes
down and it goes into the side of the
guy's house. And I watch it
on the news and I laugh. Um,
what the fuck? What the fuck am I talking
about? Why do I read some stories?
I've got, you know, some,
I gotta tell you something.
I got some great questions this week.
I got some great stories and
some great underrated overrated.
I really feel like my 14 listeners,
which I think is actually up to 22.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
I just like say in 14 you guys are
really upping your game here. And um,
Oh,
before we get into the stories,
everyone who submitted me who made
the finals for that DVD competition,
could you please resend me your addresses?
Half of you haven't.
Two of you sent me your addresses and
I lost the emails because I'm a fucking
moron. But um, I don't want to get,
I don't want to get charged
with some sort of a,
I don't want to be on like the news,
you know,
those investigative reporting things.
You had a podcast.
It was only doing okay,
so they decided to give away some DVDs,
but the DVDs never came.
Um,
I wanna I want to send them out. So
for the love of God. All right, Bill,
why don't you shut the fuck
up and read the story? Okay.
Here's a great story for
you. Um, you know, I do my
whole little rants about the,
uh, the automated checkout
lines in, uh, in grocery stores.
And how [inaudible] they're bullshit.
I don't think it's technological
advancement. It's technical,
technological advancement will be if I
just walked up and somehow I just stood
there and magically this machine knew
what fuck I owed and then I paid and then
I left.
That would be an advancement.
But to come up with an automated
machine where now I go up,
there is no cashier and then I become
the cashier to me is not technological
advancements. That's me working
at the grocery store for free.
So one of my disciples who actually
believed in this said, hey bill,
here's something that happened to you
yesterday. You might appreciate. He said,
I was in a stop and shop yesterday.
So I'm guessing that's east coast right
though. Let's go to the stop and shop,
get a fucking 30 pack.
This throws dude,
I was in stop and shop yesterday and
just grabbing a couple of things.
There was one lane open and the four
empty self check, uh, registers.
So basically one lane's open with the
cashier and then there's four of those
automated things that
are wide open. And, uh,
so he says [inaudible] remembering the
point you made in the podcast a few weeks
ago about the whole self check concept.
I got back into the open line,
um, behind five or six people,
I guess that's the cashier line.
The girl who stays by the self check
lanes came over and said she noticed that
only had a few things and that I could
you just use the self checker and be out
of there quicker. I just
said, no, that's okay.
I'm not going to do your
people's job for you.
After she heard that, she was like,
excuse me. So it was like nothing.
I have no problem waiting.
I'm just not doing your job for you.
So she walks away and about a minute or
two later a manager comes over to me and
ask if there's a problem.
So I keep my composure at this point
and tell him there's no problem.
Then I just rather wait online
than ring up my own stuff.
He then goes on to tell me
that his employee told him
that I was being rude and
disrespectful and that he was going to
ask me to leave the store. I said to him,
are you serious?
I didn't even raise my voice.
I just told her I'd rather wait in
line and that the other people online
standing next to me can vouch for me.
Of course when he asked the
other people what happened,
nobody said a Goddamn word to defend me
because I was apparently in aligned with
a group of Helen Keller's typical
spineless fucking pussies. Right.
So this is his final point.
He says,
I understand that the girl was just trying
to help me out by suggesting that I,
I use that line to get
out of the store quicker.
But when I calmly told
her that I was fine,
she didn't have to make up some
bullshit story to spite me.
When the day comes,
when cashiers are phased out and all
there is is self check registers and that
content is out of a job,
I will have a nice chuckle to myself.
You know something Mike,
I can't get mad a on that one.
I actually got annoyed
by that girl and if she lost a
job, but you know, I don't know.
I think you're right on that one.
Although I got to admit, you know, you,
you know to use the narrows
line in Goodfellas, you a yeah,
you insulted a little bit, a little
bit. He kind of insulted her.
You've got to go nicer next time and
just say, listen. You know what I mean?
I don't want you to lose your job.
Those two of those machines,
I'd taken your job and I don't
want to be a part of that.
So I'd rather stand in line here so you
guys can keep making a paycheck if you
set it that way.
But you kind of went a little bit,
a little bit when a little
hostile and you will like, yeah,
I'm not doing your job for you. You
know? I mean, I don't know. Did you have,
you know, so go fuck yourself tone. I
have no idea. But you know something.
I totally back you when you think that,
you know.
Well I would, I would have
been living in that situation.
I wouldn't have been able to control
myself when that manager came over,
I would've been like, I
didn't say anything and I
would swim in like, you know,
these machines are bullshit. At that
point I would occur. So they'd be like,
I'm sorry, so you need to, you
need to leave the store. So, um,
I don't know that make any sense. It's
like, I agree with you and I scolded you.
I agree with you. When she doesn't
have a job, I'll be fucking happy too.
And you know,
I dunno.
I don't know what the, well that's,
that's, that's a, that's a rough one.
That is rough one.
I'm just fucking out of it today.
I had a real fucking bad time
last night of comedy clubs. I,
two different people coming up to
me saying shit like, uh, you know,
I'm not even going to fucking say it.
It's just one of those things where
another comic comes up to you and as they
compliment you on a joke, you know that
they're going to steal it. You know,
they do that shit, you know, you know,
I really liked that joke you did about
the blah blah blah blah blah. You know,
it's just amazing.
You know when I watch comics,
all the different takes
people have on things.
Now let me guess. Your take is the same
as my take, except you switched to words.
You fucking Cock sucker. I'm all
right. Next story. Hey Bow. Uh,
thanks for driving that faggy hybrid.
He says always nice to read
on a fucking Monday. Hey Bill,
thanks for driving that faggy hybrid
every bit you guys save ensures that that
ensures just that much more
for me to use in my muscle car.
Was wondering if you've got something
that looks like a car or did you get the
one shaped like a butt plug?
All kidding aside.
I dig you stand up podcast, all
that shit. Awesome. Um, no hybrid.
Looks like a buck plug. I [inaudible] I
didn't know what a buck plug looks like.
I imagined it looks like something
that you stick in the sink.
And then when a butt plug looks like,
I'm like, oh, he's calling me a fag. But
he knows what a butt plug looks like.
You know something? I'm going to chime
in early on. The underrated overrated.
You know what's overrated?
Muscle cars.
Muscle cars are so fucking overrated.
It's ridiculous.
If you've seen those things,
those auctions,
they have these fucking baby boomer Geek
fucking rich douche bags are spending
like 150 grand to get a 68 Mustang.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Fucking idiots probably
can't even change the oil.
They want to go in there and get the,
you know,
the body off restoration playing 150
fucking thousand dollars for a Mustang,
the Mustang. You know what
I mean? If fucking idiot,
you could literally go buy a
piece of Shit Mustang, you know,
not piece of shit,
but it's got a decent body and just
throw new fucking engine in it.
Why would you spend 150 grand?
What is that?
It's got the original well roll
the window down handles. You know,
in 1968 these were actually shut up.
It's not worth 150 grand.
Those cars are so fucking grossly
overpriced. Those are overpriced.
Those vintage guitars. I
don't, there's any musicians,
those fucking beat up fucking fenders and
Les Pauls from 40 50 years ago that I,
you know, can't play. You can't
fucking play. There's no reason.
There's no guitar that's worth
50 fucking thousand dollars.
And they got the shit kicked out of them.
They're all worn out.
They look like shit. I don't understand
it. So we bought the point the other day.
Well let's Stevie Ray Vaughn,
he used to play an old guitar.
He got an a pawn shop.
He probably paid fucking 30
bucks for it can tell you right.
Not that thing was 50 grand.
He would've been playing a Ukulele
on the Texas flood album. Um,
but anyways, I, why did people think they
are so manly? If they have a muscle car,
I don't fucking understand it.
It's like you can get one for 15 grand.
Sounded like I couldn't afford to buy one.
I just fucking idiot.
And it just automatically makes you gay.
I gotta admit it's a little tires,
this little tires or make it faggy
and you know what? The guys, right?
They are faggy they all saggy. Look, I
don't know if they look like blood plugs,
you know? Sorry. You know what?
At the risk of having the FBI come to
my door to find out what I'm doing,
I'm actually going to go on the Internet
right now and I'm going to fucking
Google images but plugs,
you know what I picture I picture like I
literally picture like a little plug in
and it has like the threads.
Like you'd literally screw it in
and then it's got that little metal ring.
He just,
because he does sort of pull it out.
All right is,
but with two butt plug,
I'm going to have to fucking burn this
fucking iPod after I do this images.
All right bud. Plug search images
for a buck plug. Here we go.
Jesus Christ.
That looks like a fucking grenade.
Customed buck.
There's a Paris Hilton but plug and it's,
it's shaped like a hand.
Oh my God.
He's a horrific Fox tail buck plug.
Cause a family circus with a butler.
Wow.
These are creepy sex toys.
A creepy.
Okay. These are gross.
Um, in to save you guys.
Well, I can't explain what they
look like. I guess they look like
they look like Christmas
trees with the stand.
That's the only way I can describe
it. It's the same shape. That's grubs.
That's fucking gross seed.
See what to see the level.
You just fucking brought this podcast
down too. That was really disgusting. Um,
anyways, we know something. The audio
of this will save me if the FBI comes.
I'm like p towns and I was
just the one research. Um,
all right, next one. Hey Bill,
I saw you on,
uh,
on comedy central and December and
I'd been listening to you ever since.
I know how strongly you feel about people.
What the fuck is this
using the self checkout,
which I agree with and I was wondering
how you feel about people paying bills
online. This is a great
question. How do you,
what do you feel about people paying bills
online? Um, I'll tell you what I feel.
I think you're out of your fucking
mind. If you pay your bills online. Um,
I know it's easier and it's
more convenient, but uh,
you know that bullshit where they
sit there and they try to say like,
this is a completely secure site.
You don't have to worry,
but that this fucking nerds out there
breaking into the fucking computer at the
Pentagon, you sh he should
never pay your bills online.
He shouldn't buy anything online.
You shouldn't do any of that.
You're rolling the dice. Cause I'm not
gonna lie to you. I do it. I do it.
But every time it's fucking stupid.
I, I, I won't pay my bills online.
I certainly won't do that. Online
banking, you're going to put your fucking,
your be a balance. You fucking, uh,
account number,
all of that shit.
You're going to put that online yet
you're outta your writing, your mind,
you out of your mind. But this
guy is basically saying, ah,
I'm probably beating a dead horse, but
the less mail that needs to be delivered,
the less carriers they need.
My brother is a mail carrier
and it fucking pisses me
off that people don't want
to pay 42 cents to mail a letter. I
mean, come on, I'm a tight ass myself,
but you can't, you can't buy shit
with 42 cents. What do you think? Um,
I dunno man, email, email
people back and forth. I mean,
there is an element of technology to
it, but I will tell you this, like,
I will forever pay bills by you using,
uh,
the male. I'm a male man. I just,
I dunno. It just seems, I mean,
not saying that people can't
fuck with you mail, but I dunno.
I think you're out of your
fucking mind if at the very least,
if you do your banking online,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Unless you don't have shit anyways, so you
don't have any money. Who gives a fuck?
Right. That's one of the great
things about being broke. You know,
when you want to punch
someone in the face, she can,
you don't have to worry
about getting sued by,
I guess you've gotta worry going to
jail and you can't afford a good lawyer.
I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about. Um, anyways,
let's talk about shit I have coming up.
Um,
I'm going to be at a wiseguy comedy club,
uh,
this weekend in Ogden,
Utah. And this is my, uh,
the first time I've ever been out.
I did a college,
there are a number of years ago.
Uh,
but I can't remember the last time I
was out when the fuck was I on Utah.
I don't remember. But anyways, it's,
the show was on a February 20th.
And the website is
www.wiseguyscomedy.com.
If you're on my website,
you can click on the link.
It's right to the left hand side of
the page and clicked on Ogden. Uh,
I'm going to be there for one
night, one night, only two shows.
And uh, and that's it. Wait a second.
What the fuck are they saying here on
the website? Oh, they got it right.
They got it right.
So there you go.
So if you saw many comedy central wrote
a whole new fucking hour and a, yeah.
So while you Mormons,
whatever the hell you guys are out there,
you Byu fans, come on out to the
show and I'll make you fucking laugh.
And then I'll go back to my hotel room
and stare out the window wondering what
happened. It's actually a scary place
to land, if I remember correctly.
Salt Lake City is surrounded by mountains,
so they kind of have to fly over them.
And then at the last second
do like a military landing,
just dropped like 10,000 feet,
I believe.
Um, Alrighty. Here we go. Let's get into
the podcast. Questions for the week,
for the week. All Right, Bill, question
number one. Uh, every now and then,
every now and again on shows like access
Hollywood entertainment tonight or x or
extra,
they let the everyday working class
person know how much television and movie
stars make.
Every time I hear the ungodly amounts,
I'm disgusted as well.
I should be. Alrighty.
Fully understanding the gluttony
involving the government and the banks.
Uh, what about these repulsive
repulsively overpaid stars?
Um,
I don't,
why are you comparing celebrities to a
banks that stole from everybody's 401k?
You know, what's the worst to star
can do? Put out a movie high bid.
Say It's good and you're out 10 bucks.
You know what I mean? And they usually,
most of them fall off after
three years. And, um, I dunno,
I don't think they're grossly overpaid.
I think they are overpaid because the
actors underneath them don't make as much
as they used to. And the main
person, I guess gets most
of the money. But, you know,
look, you fucking make a movie
and you have me star in it,
or you have Tom Cruise star in it.
You know what I mean? You can't say,
Tom Cruise isn't worth the fucking money.
You put Tom Cruise in it.
It's guaranteed the fucking things
going to make $100 million. Basically.
He's been doing that for 25 years. I don't
think that that guy's overpaid. So, uh,
and I, I don't, I don't agree with that.
I don't think that you could, you know,
government stealing money
and bank stealing money. You
can say that. Celebrities,
uh, I dunno. I don't think
that's the same thing.
Not to mention celebrities have no
privacy. What's so fucking ever and uh,
I think they get paid right about what
they deserve because when you get to that
level of fame, you need a huge
house with a wall around it.
You need your own movie theater,
you need your own tennis courts cause
you can't fucking go anywhere. You know,
because eventually you're going to have
to pick your nose and it's going to be
on the cover of a magazine.
So you need, you know,
200 foot shrubs so you can comfortably
get the underwear out of your ass and do
what fucking human beings do.
Does that make any sense?
All right bill.
I watched a lot of standup comedy.
I critique it to death. I analyzed
the joke delivery, wording,
timing,
everything does the size.
What could've been done differently
to make it funnier when I watched you
perform a,
everything you do and say seems to be
spot on and it went perfectly planned.
I was wondering,
when you watch your own specials,
do you find parts that you are unhappy
with or feel you could have done much
better or differently? Yeah, the
whole fucking thing. I won't when I,
when I go to edit it,
I watch it one time I watched it
one time with one eye closed and,
uh, and then I never watch it again.
I'm going to be one of those people,
like if I ever get my own TV show,
I will never watch one episode of it.
Yeah.
It's not a fucking natural thing to see
the back of your head or see what the
side of your face looks like or to
hear what your voice sounds like. Oh.
To watch you hold in a glass.
It's not natural to be outside of yourself
watching yourself. It's just fucking,
you know, you're having, it's like
this outer body experience. It's just,
it's fucking weird. And uh, I dunno if
you're comfortable doing it. I don't,
I think that's, I don't know more power
to you, but I can't fucking do it.
So yeah, I always think of, I think
about stuff all the time. Well, my, uh,
you know, certain times
my Hbo Special Man, I, I,
that one was a number one wasn't too hard
to watch because that one went great.
Why do I do this? Wasn't too
hard to watch, but those, I
only watched him one time,
but like a, a bunch of shit
earlier on earlier on in my career.
You know what it is, it's when it's
on TV, that's when it freaks me out.
Like if I fill my sense self last night,
you know,
at the comedy store or whatever,
I could go home and I could watch it and
I wouldn't have a problem watching it
and I could actually enjoy it.
But the second I know it's going to be
on TV and a as a fucking cell phone,
my girlfriend's cellphone,
California dreaming Hump Gaze us fly.
Hey, it's your phone. Um, anyway,
um, what was I gonna say? Yeah, so, but
the second I know it's going to be on TV,
that's when it freaks me out. And
then I'm like, oh my God, you know,
anywhere from fucking a thousand
people to fucking whatever.
How many people fucking watch comedy
central, however many of that is,
are going to see this shit.
And then everything I do,
any little screw up that I do becomes,
you know,
900 feet tall and I freaked the fuck
out and probably comes down to the fact
that I don't like myself. Aw, that's
sad though. Why don't you like yourself?
Um, I don't know. Working
on it. All right, Bill,
what would you attempt it?
This is the person that asked me
a bunch of new agey questions.
What would you attempt to do if
you knew you would not fail? Uh,
jump off a tall building. You know, I
guess I would've failed by jumping up,
jumping off a building and living,
you know,
I just want to feel that that
adrenaline adrenaline rush feels like,
cause you're like, ah, kids, you're
going down. I do something like that.
Um, I know that person wanted something
a lot deeper than that. Let me see here.
What would you, what would you attempt
to do if you knew you wouldn't fail?
Uh, what would I do? Ah,
Jesus Christ. I'd probably try
to do some Gandy Shit, you know,
if I wouldn't get assassinated,
I wish I had that kind of charisma.
If I could lead a Gandy revolt against
these fucking automated cashier machines,
you know, I shoot small, you know
what I mean? Gandhi. You know,
what did he get? He got England to fucking
leave India. What things does he get?
He gets shot in the back of the fucking
head. Or at least Ben Kingsley did.
I never, I don't know much
about the real Gundy. Actually.
You know what's funny when
I pictured Gandhi, a picture
Ben Kingsley as Gandy. Um,
number two, Bill, you had two
identities. If you had two identities,
one is yourself and one is an animal. What
kind of animal would you be? You know,
something. I feel like I'm in a
really bad date right now. Uh,
what kind of animal would I be?
Something that could run the fuck away
really fast from these questions? Um,
if I could be one animal,
I think it'd be a bird.
Cause I've always thought how to fly.
What kind of animal would I be?
Uh,
something poisonous so I can fucking
bite you on your ankle. No, that's mean,
I don't know. What's my favorite
animal? I like bears. So stupid.
Question number three,
Bill,
what is one of the most valuable lessons
you have learned so far to proofread
the questions? Know what does the
mall, I'm really trashing this person.
He's a good question. You know
what? Don't don't. Don't be if you,
if you're the person who wrote this,
you listen to me right now.
Don't feel bad that you wrote these.
Okay, this has nothing to do with you.
This has to do with me,
and all of a sudden you're tapping into
an emotional level in me that I'm not
comfortable exposing.
All right?
This is feeling like I have to relax
and open up and it's just really fucking
creeping me out.
All right,
let me fucking white knock on my
way through this last one. Bill,
what is one of the most valuable
lessons you have learned so far?
Whether you learned it,
watching someone else go through the
situation or you expected at yourself,
experienced it yourself. Uh Oh, uh, yeah.
I would say that life
doesn't have to be hard,
that you don't have to be miserable and
that you don't have to be surrounded by
a bunch of cons and that a,
if that's how you grew up,
you know,
without even realizing it,
you go out into the world and you
surround yourself with those same kinds of
people just because you're used to it.
And then maybe one day you get to,
what I figured out about a year
ago, it was like, hey, you know,
I really don't have to hang out
with a bunch of assholes. You know?
I think that's why so many
marriages don't work out.
It's because you just want to get away
from your family and then you go out and
you end up marrying
the exact same kind of,
uh, fuck. I was just having
this conversation last night
over a couple of bears.
You know, whatever misery you grew
up with, if you're not careful,
you go out and you marry it. You
know, expecting change. Don't, don't,
uh, I guess that's what I, I've, I've,
uh, I can't even say I learned it.
I noticed it. I noticed that. I was
like, Hey, look at that shit over there.
All right, good. That's, you
guys really want to freak me out.
Ask me some new agey questions and
that'll be a new section of the podcast.
We get to watch me squirm and be fucking
uncomfortable. Probably up to right now.
29 minutes. All right. I'm gonna try to
keep these a little bit shorter here.
All right. Hey, bill, have you
ever gotten revenge on a person,
on an object or an object,
like a printer in office space?
That movie? Um, I gotta admit
I'm not a big revenge person.
Uh, I don't feel comfortable with it. I
always like that goes to a really dark,
dark place that's like a, you holding
the hand of the devil when you,
when you do some shit like that.
Like I walk away,
if someone really fucks me over,
I just let them learn.
I walk away like, I've never,
uh, you know, you know,
if I ever dated a girl and she fucked
me over something, I just always,
I just said, fuck it. I walked away. It's
just not worth it. It's not worth it.
I'm not doing it.
And I know me is not only,
you know,
have I just gotten fucked over and now
I'm going to seek revenge and his odds
are that I'm going to get
caught seeking revenge.
And that's the worst because that's
like one time I had like I want to,
first time I lived out here in La,
I came back from being on the road for
two weeks and there was a, there was, uh,
a note on my door saying that,
that they needed to check my
smoke alarms and that they will,
they needed to check them
by this certain date.
And by the time I got off the road, the
date was literally like a week earlier,
right?
So evidently they had the legal right
to go into my apartment because if there
was a, if my smoke detectors,
you know, our faulty, a fire,
my apartment affects the other units.
That was their reasoning.
So I walked in there and I could just
immediately tell that someone who had been
in my apartment. And, uh,
there's one of these deals back in the
day when I really did the road for a long
time. Like when I came back, you know,
from the, I've been on the road so long,
like all the water and basically
evaporated out of my toilet,
you know what I mean?
Those was like half an inch of water,
like that type of shit.
Right.
And I was sitting there and I sat
down, I was like, fucking eat.
I don't know what it was.
Some sort of a say ESP,
I don't want the fucking proper term is,
but I could just feel it.
I was like,
something's not right.
And I got up and I looked through my
apartment and I was mentioned missing a
camera.
I was missing a watch and the person
had picked through my CD collections.
Evidently they will a rap fan, cause
that's all they took. And uh, you know,
nickel and dime shit. So I went downstairs
to the management and I was like,
you know,
I come back from being on the road.
You say you're going to check my
smoke detectors and I walk in there,
I'm just gonna Watch Mrs CD's.
I missed some cameras.
The place is still locked from the inside.
And the guy immediately just
snapped on me, says, look,
I don't appreciate you calling the were
accused and Booboo, booboo, booboo.
And I'm like, I didn't accuse
anybody. I didn't accuse anybody.
I don't appreciate you standing here
getting upset with me. Like on this guy.
Just,
he totally tried to grill his way through
the shit and at one point he's just
like, whatever. He's like, I
have the power, I have the power.
He literally said that and I wanted to
reach across and just rip this guy's
fucking throat out.
So my girlfriend at the time goes, you
know who the guy is? I'm like, yeah.
She goes, you know where
his car is? Yeah. She goes,
you should go down and fuck up his car.
And I really thought about doing it,
but I was like, all right, you
just went down to the guy's office.
You just had a really heated
argument with that fucking guy.
There was people there witnessed it.
You know what I mean?
There's camera's in the garage.
If I do it,
I know I'm going to get fucking caught.
So, uh, actually I did get revenge.
What am I talking about?
I know what I did instead I
stood outside the office and uh,
what did I do that's no, no, no. I think
it was still part of the arguments.
Someone came walking in and they were
getting ready to rent a apartment in the
building and I told him the story.
I go and I came back off the road and
there's stuff missing and I'm talking to
this guy and this guy is yelling at me.
I'm telling you the elevators to slow.
And the two people like thanks a lot.
And they walked out.
And then I looked at the guy and I said,
let me tell you something.
I'm a comedian.
I don't work days.
I will sit out here every single day in
a lawn here and I'll tell every person
who comes walking in there and I saw
the guy getting nervous and I knew I was
completely full of shit because I had
to go on and on the road again the next
day. And uh, so yeah,
I never seek revenge and it still bugs
me and I tried to lie to myself going,
you know what? He'll get
his, that guy will get his,
and you know what I've realized,
uh, those guys don't get this.
They continue to rob and steal, but
I don't know, maybe they miserable.
Do you guys believe in that shit?
Do you think that they, you know,
rent vengeances mindset of the Lord,
you believe in that shit?
I kind of believe in it and then I'll
let them sometimes I think, well,
it didn't just some rich
people, right? The Bible.
So I would feel comfortable being
poor. Yeah. And we fuck you over.
Don't take vengeance on us. Don't worry.
This invisible guy after we'll dead,
we're dead.
He'll take care of us.
That's the one thing why I
don't believe in the Bible,
cause everyone who preaches
it is living this, this,
this lifestyle that they would
not get into heaven. You know,
like look at George Bush.
George Bush is a Jesus Freak.
The guy's out of his fucking mind. You
know, he's out of his fucking mind.
Would Jesus, you know,
somehow take us to war.
I'm not trying to get political here,
let's say,
and the guy did the right thing or
the wrong thing. I don't fucking know.
But I'm just saying, you know,
if I was truly a Jesus Freak,
I would not advocate going to war.
And one of the things that scares me
about fucking people get into religion is
the more religious they get, the more
violent and unaccepting they get up.
Other people.
That is one of the most hackiest things
I've ever said because other people have
made that point. But it's
fucking true. It's true.
Like I don't give a shit about gay guys,
you know,
they can fucking blow each other all
day long. What the fuck do I care?
Then I'd heard anybody, you
know, I don't want to see it,
but we have laws against that.
Don't blow your boyfriend out
in the fucking street, you know,
but I think you ought to be able to do it
on a Futon, you know, behind some walls.
I don't think you're going to hell.
I mean,
for me it would be a hellacious
experience, but you know, all right.
Just continue on a bill. You made your
point and now you're going to ruin it.
All right, plow ahead. All
right. Hey Bill. On TV,
they sometimes talk about how it costs
$11 trillion to have Chris rock come to
your house and do 15 minutes of stand up.
How much will it cost to have bill Burke
come over to a fan's house and perform,
stand up for 50 minutes? When
a great fucking question, um,
it would cost you, I do it
for, I do it for 12 bucks,
but I would have some riders attached to
it that would up the performance price.
Okay. First off, um, there
has to be some sort of stage.
Okay.
And it literally could be that brick
part that comes out from your fireplace.
I'll stand on that. I may
be an Ottoman. You know
what's an automation?
Is the thing you put your clothes in or
is that the thing you put your feet on?
I'm talking about the thing you put
your feet on on one of those things.
And also I have to be helicoptered in.
Do you have to have a
backyard as big enough?
It's big enough for me to land in.
Okay.
And then I'm going to get
off the helicopter and I'm
going to be wearing a scarf.
Silk scarf that you pay for that I will
never address during my performance.
No one at the party is allowed
to make eye contact with me.
Everyone will sit around the fucking
Automato that thing you put your feet on
Indian style and I will do my jokes and
I will not look at any of you. I will.
I will fucking be staring
at the toaster the entire,
I want to toast her in the back of
the room. I'll do this to 12 bucks.
You pay me $12 you helicopter me in,
you by the scarf.
I will stand on a fucking
ornament and I will do,
I'll do 25 minutes for 12 bucks.
All right,
you got the fucking 12 bucks and the money
to book the helicopter. I will do it.
I'm really talking to myself and
do a fucking youtube moment and um,
that's it.
But no one can make eye contact with me.
Just like pope of Greenwich
Greenwich Village.
And you don't say good night to nobody
that when she got to stare at the fucking
floor when she walks out,
um,
you know something that's, that's the
tandem. I'm waiting to get back together.
Everybody talks about Walter Matthau
and Jack Lemmon back in the day.
What about Mickey Work and Eric Roberts?
Can they get together again?
Nikki work is back.
I think it's time for those guys to do
another fucking movie before the two
Goddamn old. So there you go. There's
your, there's your answer. 12 bucks,
the helicopter ride. No eye contact,
a scarf and a fucking Ottoman.
And you've got yourself a comedian,
but not for 50 minutes. All right.
Give me 24 bucks.
I'll do the 50 minutes.
Alright, here we go. Um, overrated.
Underrated. Okay. Uh,
underrated. Um, how awesome.
Whoever the first guy was to
coin the phrase mustache ride.
I have to admit, I've never
heard of this, this phrase,
how much confidence and creepiness
does one have to ooze in order to say
something like that to an actual living,
breathing woman?
Probably happen sometime during this,
the 70s,
when everyone was sporting a
mustache and a leisure suit. Oh,
is that what you did back in the day?
Actually,
I didn't like stick a mustache
ride. Eh, I don't know.
I've never heard of that one. Um, oh,
here's a good one. Uh, underrated.
What red wine will do to your
erection? True Story. A while back,
I had a girl over for dinner at my place.
I drank about three glasses of wine
I was expecting to make out with her.
It was kind of a first date, so I wasn't
expecting the opportunity to get laid.
So evidently this guy kept drinking.
So while the opportunity arose
to get laid and I didn't,
I was sitting on the edge
of my bed pulling my dick
like I was trying to get an
old lawn mower to start and nothing,
you know,
embarrassing this to be jerking off in
front of a girl while apologize. I think
I've been there. Um, I can never
look that girl in the eye again.
I've heard the term whiskey Dick Button.
Never heard a mention of red wine.
How come? No one ever told me
that that could happen. Um,
I think whiskey Dick just sort of was
supposed to be all encompassing of alcohol
in general. I think whiskey Dick,
I guess has a decent ring to it.
Beer Dick doesn't sound good wine.
Dick.
Actually whiskey Dick doesn't sound good
either. I've never liked that either.
I don't like that. Expression can be
some sort of alliteration going on there
for beer cock. That's
not good. Wine. Willie,
Willie, Willie. Why? No, I don't
know what it is, but no whiskey.
Dick Means all alcohol. But no one
ever explained that because I you,
you took it literally like,
Oh, don't drink whiskey.
I won't be able to get an erection,
but evidently I can drink fucking red wine
all night. Like some fucking divorced,
48 year old woman with two kids.
What's wrong with you as a man that
you sit there drinking red wine?
Was that her idea?
Were you wearing a scarf?
I bet you where you should
have been helicoptered in
that the have bottle of red
wine. All right. Overrated.
How excited people get over
getting their tax refund.
You know something that's one
of the best overrated ever.
That's a fucking great
one. Uh, someone's like,
I'm getting 3000 back from the government,
2000 back from the 16,000 they,
they took from me throughout the year.
And the kicker is that while I was
sitting in my accountant's office,
I don't really use government. I realized
I don't really use government services.
I don't have any kids in school.
I live in New York City,
so I don't drive on state roads.
I'm 27 and I've never needed a
cop throughout my whole life.
I never called the fire department.
I'd never been on welfare.
The only thing that governor has done
for me in the past year is pick up my
garbage and make sure
I get more HD channels.
I realize I have to pay taxes and
ultimately I don't mind doing it,
but in hindsight,
13,000 is way too much to pay to
have someone take away your garbage.
That's more than a thousand bucks a month.
I could drive a top of the line
Lexus for that type of money. Yeah,
and put your garbage in the trunk and
take it over to the dump. Exactly.
Well know what the funny thing is about
people getting their tax refund back.
They're all excited and they don't read.
They never stopped to think that you gave
the government an interest free loan.
Like you could have had that three
grand plus the money that you owed the
government shitting in your
bank account or whatever,
earning interest and then the end of the
year you could just give him the money
that you owed him. He should. What does
that he claimed zero. Is that what it is?
That's what you should do.
And then you
get some sort of psycho accountant to
whittle the fucking charges down and then
you pay him. That's how you
do it in order is most people,
they don't want to deal, you know, and
they just kind of look at that dude,
it's money in the bank. No, it isn't. It
isn't money in the bank. It's money lost.
That's what it is.
And then what do they do when they get
their fucking money back? What do they do?
They go out and they take it and they go
out and buy a shiny liability that went
on. I brought a fucking flat screen dead.
That's what I did. And that's great.
That's great. He realized the
second you hung it on your wall.
It's worth 600 bucks
now. You dumb fuck. Um,
underrated mom and pop hardware stores,
emailing classic Bruce Lee
Kung Fu movies and good girls.
Oh, good girls is so
underrated. So underrated.
Why do we always pick the
horse fellows? Huh? Why?
You know why?
Because you dick your Dick.
It's gift fucking Dick. I
don't even explain it. I
don't even need to explain it.
It just goes back to that dump discovery
channel thing. The same way the lions,
you know the lionesses is sitting
there and when they look at the herd,
do they go after the best gazelle?
Now they go after the weakest
one cause it's the easiest kill.
That's what it is. It's fucking
wanted is all right. A overrated, um,
giant corporate stores.
I phones Jackie Chan
movies and Valentine's Day,
really one day out of the
year where the price of roses,
teddy bears and chocolates skyrockets
because some naked baby wants to fly
around,
shoot narrows and people's asses.
Just surprise your girl on
a random day with that shit.
She won't expect it and will appreciate
a hundred times more than if you did it
on Valentine's state. Could not agree
with you more. I got to say something.
You guys are really up in your fucking
game here. You know, great questions,
great underrated,
overrated, great stories.
I mean I didn't have to do shit this week.
I just sat here and fucking read
it like a fucking local newscaster,
which is kind of good cause I think I was
kind of off my game today sitting here,
my freezing fucking cold apartment.
I got this awful heater.
You know what I mean?
It's the only place where I live in.
It's a really cool building,
but it's old as fuck.
It's like one of those old time Hollywood,
you know,
back when it said Hollywood land,
that's when this thing was built.
It was made in the uh,
late 1930s.
I like living in an old places like
that, but you know, sucks the heat them.
And I always like think about the
conversations, you know what I mean?
Like shit that happened. Like, you know,
I bet Charlie chaplain came over here
and bank some want to be starlet in my
shower.
Is Little Hitler mustache getting
all fucking wet. You know,
I'm just picturing Charlie Chaplin
still wearing that fucking that hat and
making that I'm fucking
you real good face.
You know when you bite your lower lip.
Oh he was probably all nervous too
because what happened to fatty Arbuckle?
But he still had to do it. You know, cause
he didn't pick a good girl. He doesn't,
he went over here and fucked the whore.
You know?
That's what I always want.
You ever wonder about?
You want to get it all apartments?
You just wonder what the fuck happened.
You know like this,
this place was around
like right before World War II.
All the conversations that have
taken place, all that stuff,
the amount of people from different
generations bitching about how this heater
doesn't work. I don't know. The red scare,
Kennedy getting whacked
the white flight in Detroit.
I don't know why I just brought that up.
You know why?
Cause the guy fucking shaves my head from
Detroit and he lived through all that
shit.
Detroit is such a sad fucking city.
This guy was telling me how back in the
day some of the richest people in the
world lived in Detroit back when the
big three was the big three in the Ford
family. They all live there and
because they had all this cash,
all these great department stores,
all these museums in Detroit,
look at it. Years later.
Eight Mile Eminem, kid rock
these angry fucking white kids cause
they grew up in a fucking BFI. Been
once a Vfi been bill.
Well that's the name of the fucking
waste management in Massachusetts.
A garbage dumpster
dumpster. Right. All right.
I guess that's it. That's, you know I
had rainy Monday energy on this one,
but um,
what are you gonna do?
You can't have a bitch about these fucking
things cause they're free. All right?
And if you are, go fuck yourself
it cheap. Fuck. You know,
I've actually had, you know,
people criticize my podcast.
Dylan wasn't as good as lists. Weeks.
Rarely do you feel cheated out of money.
You fucking cunt. You know, and
Howard, it is the Babel by yourself.
Wow. All the way up to 47
minutes. I really have diarrhea,
the fucking mouth here.
All right, let me get off the
phone here. All right, so here,
here's some of my upcoming gigs.
I have a a Gig on a
uh, shit. What is a fucking date of it?
[inaudible] Ogden this weekend
and I'm going to be, uh,
I have an la date coming
up. Hang on. Hang on,
let me open it up with a fuck. Is
it? I don't know what the fuck it is.
Shit.
I'm going to be at the comedy store
doing a show on, oh, I know.
I go into my cell phone here.
This is garbage time
right now. Irvine. What?
I guess I want to be in Irvine and the
Irvine Improv on February 24th is that
right? You know what? I have the
next week it'll be no big deal,
but I got a couple of La la shows
coming up. Um, you know what?
I have to call somebody right now.
You want to give me a call
and ask somebody about what
the fuck when the my next
Gig is,
is your life that empty or you really,
is that how much you
hate your fucking job?
You're actually going to listen to
this phone call. It is, isn't it?
You got to do a gut check right now.
Who is that computer late. Please enjoy
the music while your party is reached.
I'm on hold right now. Hang on. Hey
Jeff, when am I doing that show with you?
At the comedy store.
February 26th okay,
cool. All right. I just need to put it,
I'm going to put it on my website
right now. All right. Okay. All right.
I'll look. I'm doing good. I
got somebody on the other line.
Let me call you right back.
Okay. Bye. Huh? You like that?
All right.
February 26th,
I'm going to be at the
comedy store and uh,
in Los Angeles doing not Jeff Richard
Show. It's a show to help benefit,
uh, hungry people. People
don't have any food, you know,
and it's not starving people
either. It's just, you know,
like you have a busy been driving
around time like I fuck, I'm starving.
Those kinds of people, people who
actually knew like have eaten that day,
but they haven't eaten in six hours
so they feel like they're starving.
We're actually going to help him out.
You know,
cause everybody's helping out
those starving kids in Africa.
Anybody can do that shit.
Who actually helps out start from
people who technically aren't starving.
They just haven't eaten in awhile and
their bodies are now breaking down the
muscle that they built up at the gym.
All right.
Thank you very much for listening.
Um,
please keep the great podcast questions
coming. The underrated overrated,
the movie reviews, calling my car.
Faggy whatever the fuck you want to do.
And, uh, that's it. I'll look at the sun
came out right at the end of the podcast.
Isn't that beautiful?
Talk to you next week.
Wow.
[inaudible]
the
river
of words from
Sanibel, the shower burns.
Wigan Palace,
the Queen
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] like with
my husband. And he's like sitting
there sipping tea with the wife.